No, the title isn't ClickBay.
I actually went on basically a day trip from the East Coast
to the West Coast just for a maid cafe.
Welcome to Ton Tokotan Maid Cafe in Little Tokyo, Los
Angeles.
It's based off of the maid cafe from the anime Akiba
Mid-War.
And it's a collaboration between High Dive, Sci Games,
Sentai Filmworks, and Akiba Pop-Up and Live.
So I landed sometime around midnight the previous day, and
then the next day did literally nothing in my hopes.
hotel room until it was time to head over to little Tokyo.
I ended up being a little early to try and avoid too much
traffic, so it was fun to walk around and I saw that guy.
A week before the event, I was invited to join the opening
day of the maid cafe and get a sneak peek of what it was
going to be all about.
And you know, being the maid enthusiast I am, of course I
had to answer the call.
It also feels like a rare opportunity to have these sorts of
events pop up in the United States.
So I basically possessed a random person and made them go
for me.
When it was time to go in, we were separated into tables and
we had our maid greeting us the moment we walked in.
Look at you, Mitchie.
She's so cute.
My first thought going in was just how authentic it felt.
You know, I've been to many, many, many, many mid cafes and
several collab cafes and not even most collab cafes are as
dedicated as everyone here made it to be.
So it was really fun and really set the atmosphere.
And you can even see how the cafe is decorated to look just
like the cafe from the show.
which you know could be a good thing or I mean it's kind of
like dingy but it works right that's how it was in the show
they had different menus you could choose from for your food
as well as entertainment menus but you know baby's first
vlog and unfortunately I forgot to get footage of that day
but it included things such as checkies also known as
Polaroid photos performances and games with the maids they
also had original merch such as pen lights t-shirts stickers
and more.
The food was pretty standard for a maid cafe though it was a
little limited which is understandable for a pop-up.
You could choose between the porkers omurais, heart-cune
chicken curry or piglet cutlet bento which was a tonkatsu
bento.
No one at my table got the curry but the omurais and bento
both included a drawing which was really cute.
I asked for my maid to draw a ghost maid.
But maybe I should have asked for a pig like everyone else
at the table.
Oops.
There were also three types of drinks.
The oink-doink drink, the Piggy Pearl iced coffee, and the
oink-doink water.
I thought based off the name, the coffee would have some
jelly in it, but it was just plain coffee.
And I can't have soda, but if you can, I suggest the
oink-doink drink because it comes with a cute little
performance from your maid, and each drink color ends up
being different, so it's really fun.
I'm not sure what exactly is on the dessert menu, but we
were given these really awesome Ronko cookies and you can
see that I got ice cream all over her face.
Oops.
What was so fun is all the Aikome is also themed for the
cafe.
Instead of your normal moe moe kune, you're squealing like a
pig saying boohy.
It's all really, really sweet.
The best part by far was the performance, though.
If you haven't watched the anime, be careful of spoilers,
but they basically did a quick rendition of the whole show
for us, which is really, really awesome.
fun watching the maids go from violet gangsters to cutesy
dancing idols and it was all songs from the anime so it was
really fun recognizing like the opening song and the insert
songs everyone was so invested in their part and making it
as authentic as possible i felt it was really worth it for
the experience and if you're in the la area while it's still
running definitely check it out the cafe runs from june 28th
to july 28th and tickets are online only in reservation so
get your ticket You can even see the cameraman from the cafe
as dressed as the debt collector from the show.
Like, come on, the level of effort was definitely there.
I also want to say, even though I was invited to go, I
wasn't sponsored at all for this trip.
Everything was out of my pocket, so these are all my real
feelings about it.
Overall, it was such a unique experience, and if you've
never been to Japan, or been to a maid cafe, or if you've
been to a maid cafe and kind of want to compare your
experiences between the two, definitely, definitely,
definitely check it out.
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.